[Music]
it's been
a tough couple of years the lockdowns
the malays all the election nonsense
that we lose trump we get this guy who's
half asleep and destroying the world and
it's just been and one of
one of the worst aspects of it all was
the disappearance of lauren southern i
always really loved watching lauren's
commentary
and then she made the fair enough
decision to go
off start a family pull back a little
bit from public life
i understand she did what she had to do
well you know what she's back
she is back and she has a unique
perspective because she left one
hellscape in the anglosphere canada
america's hat
for apparently another one which is
still locked down even down under
lauren thank you very much for coming on
thanks for having me i was really
enjoying my hiatus
my family all of it but you guys really
dropped the ball
things have just gone sideways the last
year in a bit and you felt much like
much like pacino in godfather part three
just when i think i'm out
they pulled me back in who uh and they
did and so it's gone really crazy i want
your perspective on
on two stories that i think americans
don't don't really know very much about
i i don't even know where to begin
let's begin at america's hat your former
country
they're burning down churches all
throughout
canada and no one's no one's really
talking about it
yeah other than a brief mention from
trudeau weeks after it started happening
and we're not talking about just one or
two churches here we're talking about
dozens of organized arson and vandalism
attacks against churches one evening
there were
10 attacks against churches in one
province
and all this is happening because
there have been mass graves that were
discovered of
indigenous people in canada now we don't
actually have
much information on these mass graves
we've just found
graves we haven't investigated why they
were there whether they
uh occurred because there was a disease
outbreak in fact
one of the mass graves found in british
columbia which
resulted in churches being attacked was
discovered to just be an
overgrown graveyard that they knew
was a graveyard but the media just went
off with it
mass grave this is a genocide with no
further
investigation or professionals looking
into it
and of course people are saying that
these attacks
are justified this is revenge against
the catholic church who
ran residential schools that indigenous
people went to
in the 1800s and earlier 1900s to
essentially assimilate them
to the english culture when they came
over i don't think the residential
schools were a good thing but
is hate crimes today the right reaction
to hate crimes a hundred years ago
years ago i want to pause you there just
for people because i'm not particularly
familiar with this either so there were
these residential schools
that were largely run by the church to
assimilate the native american not
native american the native canadians the
the indigenous first peoples
to the dominant canadian culture and
so i understand that by the way in
principle i'm not even opposed to
assimilation in principle if you're
gonna have a country
you need people to assimilate into that
country but this is somewhat
controversial because
what because of first nations
sovereignty and the
the canadians stole our land is that the
argument
well the idea that they were forcing
them out of their traditional cultures
and of course there was abuse also found
at some of these residential schools
uh whether it be sexual or physical
abuse but also something that should
really be understood by people jumping
up and down about this
is most boarding schools at that time in
history
were rife with abuse right no matter who
was going there i mean i was just
reading surprised by joy by c.s lewis
and
he went to a really wealthy boarding
school where he talks about abuse
occurring but yeah
i mean he he was a bit too pale for us
to care about that right
and and yeah so people are burning down
churches
as revenge and the shocking part
too is some of these churches aren't
even like
anglo catholic churches a lot of them
are on residential
indigenous land so they are actually
indigenous
churches so not only did some of these
people have to be descendants of
family members who were in residential
schools but now they have woke people
today burning their churches down to try
to
i don't know save them from past it
makes no sense
it makes no sense and you have verified
checkmark liberals
all over twitter saying they love this
saying they support this
so you you have the sort of
pro-native canadian first peoples arson
against the churches
at the same time you've got the
government going in because of the covid
police
shutting down churches shutting down
services there was a very famously this
polish canadian pastor pavel
pavlovsky was his name or no arthur
arthur pavlov yes no he
and he he was tremendous and he yelled
he said get out you gestapo
out of this property you nazis out
ouch gestapo is not allowed here
and there there are now suggestions that
religious freedom
in canada and the ability to practice
christianity is being threatened as it
is in other
nefarious countries like communist china
for instance
so so you've got this threat and i can't
help but notice
no matter who the radicals are whether
they're radical
indigenous activists whether they're
radical leftists in the government
whether it's the jacobins whether it's
the communists whether it's
they always seem to go after
the churches throughout history what's
that about
absolutely at first i want to point out
these radical indigenous
activists in a lot of cases are actually
white people
claiming they stand up for the
indigenous there have been videos that
have come out and it's like
22 year old white women privileged
attacking them it always is
saying they stand for stand for the
indigenous people who are actually the
chiefs in canada are begging people to
stop this
but the white kids have to stand up for
them and save the day by
burning down their churches of course
but yeah it's it's this attack against
christianity
because christianity is the antithesis
of everything they stand for in my
opinion they stand for
uh absolutely no restrictions
on our personal desire
no morality to constrict what we want to
do no matter how sinful or how harmful
to other people they stand for cancel
culture
so that people should just be cut off
from society cut out
irredeemable christ and redemption is
quite literally the antithesis
of cancer culture good point and they
can't have that
they need conservatives they need
christians they need these people to be
irredeemable separate from them so that
they can be seen
as the saints and the heroes they are
the good ones fighting against the
irredeemable
nazis in our society and also they're
out of nazis i mean
i'm sure they exist somewhere but
they're in swamps in alabama and they
don't have any power in society so they
keep having to find
new things to label the ultimate enemy
and right now
that is the church and it is the perfect
enemy because because it is the one
thing that is
a mere to their immorality and a mere to
the wrongdoing they have been
inflicting on the west it's a great
point and
i i've long seen this radical leftism as
just an inversion of christianity
throughout even
even up to its ultimate sacrament which
is abortion
which i think it was peter craft who
made the point even uses the language of
the eucharist this is my body
uh as a way to defend this this uh
antithesis of of the gospel you know
in the destruction of of the baby this
this is my body this is my choice
so i certainly see that in version i do
have to correct you though when you say
that there are only a few nazis running
around alabama
that's not there are very many nazis
they all work for the fbi they're all
informants they're just feds
fed nazis spying on other fed nazis so
it's a totally contrived issue but but
there are many of them
running around and so you've got this
problem in canada
obviously part of the anglosphere and
you fled you fled canada wisely i think
and now you're down under you're about
as far away from canada as one can
possibly get
i always thought australia was a good
virile tough manly culture but you
inform me
the lockdowns there are just as bad as
they are anywhere else
oh australia is a lovely country but i
just came at the absolute
worst time apparently i thought i would
be riding crocodiles and fighting off
giant spiders but i've just been
locked in my house the entire time
because yeah they are there are some of
the
worst restrictions in the world here in
australia
we're in the 700 lockdown at the moment
all the states um not allowed to leave
your house unless you have to go buy
essential goods and even so it's only
one person at a time
just today they banned browsing
stores so if you need to
just grab some food and you don't need
mayonnaise for that food you're not
allowed to go down the mayonnaise aisle
that is illegal
at the moment um only
10 people are allowed at a funeral at
the moment
you can't travel interstate it's masks
everywhere when you go out
you know we've even had restrictions for
the times
you can go out so like from you can only
leave your house from 8am to 8pm in
victoria
of course covet is far more dangerous
in in the middle of the night we know
this
it gets much worse there's no question
about it it obviously gets worse in the
middle of the night which i should note
is when you are talking to me right now
because of this time difference
a young mother we are such sadists here
at the daily wire that we're
we're having you wake up in the middle
of the night and but greatly appreciate
it
because i i think there were a lot of
people who believed
that the coveted lockdowns were all just
about getting trump out and i
i think i still largely think that was
true but as a result
they believed that once trump was gone
once the big bad guy was kicked out of
the oval office
then everything would go away
i started to question that as the
election got closer because i thought
you know this was a big power grab
and and people don't generally like to
give up political power once
once they have taken it so what's going
to happen we're now in the longest 15
days
in recorded history we still apparently
haven't slowed the spread we're going to
be slowing it for a long time
what is the end game here are we just
living in in mask world for the rest of
our lives
oh i have been asking this question for
a long time especially if you look at
the uk right now that have some of the
highest
vaccination rates worldwide i think
they're they're well over half the
population vaccinated at the moment and
they're going through a coveted spike
so we know we have been informed
you still have to wear a mask we still
have to do these lockdowns even when
you're vaccinated
because you can still get covered when
you're vaccinated
so yeah i guess we're doing this forever
i guess this is the forever lockdown and
you know what if it does get to a point
where
they realize okay we're still having
this spread with ha over half the
population vaccinated
they're going to have to make the
decision we have to open up and we have
to let it
run its course so that we just get hurt
immunity
and how punishing will that be how how
many stories
for two years will you have of people
who missed their mother or father's
death the birth of their child the
funerals
the weddings that i think there is going
to be a reckoning
if that happens and i also think that's
why the government have held out this
long
in doing these lockdown strategies is
because
it's like chasing bad money they can't
admit they were wrong
because if they admit they were wrong
people are gonna have
a bone to pick like everyone
everyone has missed some massive event
in their life that has
catastrophically impacted their mental
health i actually know more people
who have killed themselves this year
than have died of covid
wow i know more people i suppose i do
too yeah i suppose i
i do as well i mean and i i you know i
suspect i suspect that's true
of a lot of people uh you've seen uh
deaths of despair spike not just suicide
but drug overdoses
all of those sorts of things and the the
eggheads did it right i mean this was
the public health tyrants dr fauci the
high priest of progressivism the pontiff
of of our scientific state whatever he
decrees seems to go and
and this raises a real question of how
we fight back because
we seem to be arguing on the left's
terms what the left goes out there and
says they say the science
mandates that we close all your churches
the science mandates that we keep the
marijuana dispensary open but we shut
down
the local church the science mandates
that you're not allowed to go outside
even if you're at statistically like
zero risk of facing grave consequences
from this virus because of your age and
your circumstances
and so the science is mandating a whole
lot of of things that were
formerly held in the realm of the
political you know that it's it's
actually not up to these eggheads to
determine
how i would like to make prudential
judgments and live my life but
but i notice a lot of conservatives then
arguing
from those premises and saying no the
science says this or no the science says
that my view is
who gives a damn what the science says
what does the politics say
what does the ethics say what do the
people say because
last time i checked we still had a right
to control our our country
right i think this does touch into that
larger question
of basically do we have a
right to be completely safe from disease
do we have a right to be
basically in these hamster wheels of
protection
and you know fluff all the time never
facing
harm whatsoever we have a completely
harm-over society and is that now the
government's duty to create that
because we know that there will be
another virus after this perhaps an even
worse virus
or less you know a less severe virus but
then what
what question is it what degree is it
because with covet everyone said well if
it just saves one life if i wear a mask
so now every flu season do we lock down
because that could potentially save just
one life why didn't we lock down during
the swine flu why didn't we
there are so many questions of
just general philosophical debate
political debate that come from this
that i do not think
the left have answers for i do not think
the people who have put us through this
for nearly two years now have answers to
these questions i
really think that another aspect of this
them chasing bad money i also think is
the tail wagging the dog the media are
controlling the government
by making all of these politicians
terrified
of getting a headline that says this
politician killed your grandma
this politician is the reason 50 000
people died
and so they are only doing these even
though
they have numbers guys that would tell
them this lockdown is going to kill way
more people
than it's going to save just based on
economic follow
look at the third world oxfam put out a
report saying literally
millions are going to die of starvation
due to economic fallout from this
but these politicians know that's not
going to be an article during their
election season that's going to be five
years from now so all right best thing
to do lock everyone in their houses and
save myself from a
bad new york times story this was
terrifying stuff
this was why trump was in this
impossible situation where
i think his gut told him don't lock down
if you're gonna lock down don't let them
surpass the two or three weeks
don't they're never going to give up
this power but he was in this position
where
had he not gone along with whatever dr
fauci told him to do
and he already was blamed for every
single death but every
single death of pneumonia from a 99 year
old
would have been blamed on him because of
his callousness on covet so it's a very
difficult position and
the threat of the media is big here and
i i like your point on this
philosophical issue
it kind of kind of brings me to a great
point that i saw you make just a few
months ago
you know our pal ben shapiro made has
this very famous slogan
facts don't care about your feelings
it's obviously true when you're talking
about say
bruce jenner bruce jenner feels like
he's a woman but he's not really a woman
he's a man and
the reality of that doesn't care about
his feelings you made this point in a in
a terrific video you said
it's also true feelings don't care about
your facts that
politics has quite a lot to do with
feelings i actually made the same point
in my recent book it doesn't negate
ben's perfectly
obvious observation but it does add
another aspect here and i think this
gets to the problem that conservatives
have had
for not just a few decades but actually
a few centuries
going back to that jerk david hume where
we
we don't have the confidence any longer
to
derive moral truths
from the world we seem not to be willing
to say
that uh you should do this and you
shouldn't do that
we're we're stuck in this scientistic
culture
where the eggheads rule because all
we're allowed to know is that for
instance
this is a tumbler and i know that this
is a tumbler but i'm not allowed to
derive any
any true metaphysical truth from the
tumbler i can't know for instance that
the tumbler is for drinking
i can't know for instance that my body
parts have
various purposes and they shouldn't be
put to other purposes we
we seem to have surrendered
the the basis of politics as cardinal
manning says all human conflict
ultimately is theological
but do conservatives ever make those
arguments anymore no they only ever seem
to defend free speech in the abstract
they never say anything really concrete
in theory
and the only thing they ever managed to
push for of substance and politics is
another tax cut i guess but beyond that
we seem to have lost our moral reasoning
and the left sure has and i see the left
making moral arguments all the time
yeah you know a lot of people talk about
the fear they have of us becoming these
nameless faceless genderless nationless
gray check marks on a government
data book if we embrace the leftist uh
theology but i fear us just becoming
breeding coal mine working
corporate machines just consumers also
just on a business checkbook
if we go the way that conservatism is
going at the moment we are human beings
with souls our purpose is not politics
our purpose is not conservatism i've had
people i remember
meeting them over the last few years
when i was engaged in all these
political events and the one thing
driving them was the cause whether it be
trumpism or conservatism and i'm like
that is all wrong
you've got it backwards i am a mother
first i am a christian first
i am a part of my community first and
then i am only a conservative because
i care about these things and i think it
will make these things
better in my life and i love these
things
irrationally i love my child
irrationally i don't care if
the odds of saving my son's life were a
million to one and i would maybe die
if i did something i would take those
odds every time even though the facts
didn't tell me that we are motivated by
feelings we are motivated by beauty and
life and
morality in these deeper non-tangible
themes that you were just talking about
and we really do need to tap back into
that
as conservatives we need to tap into our
artistic side the side that communicates
to the soul
because there's that great quote i think
it was actually from a billboard
advertisement that said
people don't care how much you know
until they know how much you care
yeah we have to show yeah we have to
show people
why they need to care about this data
it's it's also
what yeah it's by the way it's it's not
just a subjective feeling your
your calculation million to one odds to
save your son but it might you might
have to have incur some personal risk in
that that's not just a subjective
feeling or preference or passion
it is a a moral fact that you're that
you're talking about i mean these
when you say we're real human beings and
we're we're about more than just
consuming
random cheap goods made in china and
we're about more than than just
you know ticking up gdp for a little bit
that is
that is not merely a passion of yours
and a preference and a feeling
that is a fact and i just think we
our understanding as a culture of what
is
real what is a fact what is scientific
has become so shallow and atrophied and
it's not just the left that that has
done this the right has given into this
as well and i just think we need a much
realer kind of uh politics a more
authentic politics
we're stuck between these these false
dichotomies of
big government or the individual or
somewhere
or a free speech and censorship and i
just think
real life is about more than that it's
about standards it's about
purpose it's about what we're here for i
mean what
all the cheap chinese goods in the world
all the things we can consume in the
world
don't mean anything unless we know what
they are for and ultimately we need to
know
what we are for as well right absolutely
and i think
that also comes down to a problem with
modern conservative pursuit of hyper
individualism we are just the individual
it is just about how much
you can achieve and how much money you
can earn and pull yourself up by your
bootstraps
no actually we we have a duty to our
community you are
born helpless and we die helpless and i
do not want to live in a community where
a 90 year old grandma with no one to
help her just dies because she wasn't
strong enough to pull herself up by her
bootstraps i believe
in a duty to each other i believe in
and maybe maybe that makes me a
communist a socialist i don't think it
does
it makes you concerned it's dichotomy
yeah i think that's that false dichotomy
you're talking about where
it's not just individualists versus
communists there's complexity there's
living in this tension
of facts and feelings living in this
tension of duty to each other but also
personal responsibility
but that's a hard conversation because
it's not simple
it's not just a tweet it's not just a
slogan oh
and it's not clear you know my my friend
father george rutler
has this observation when people say i
want a clear ideology i want clear
religion and he says
shallows are clear shallow thinking is
clear
deep things are profound they're a
little murky you've got to kind of work
with them and and i i see in this false
dichotomy between you know the
individualist
and the collectivist i think they're two
sides of the same coin the way that the
collectivists collectivize is by
breaking down society into a bunch of
individuals that they can more easily
bundle up together and really the
opposite of
collectivism is not individualism it's
the family
it's community it's society even the way
that we talk about our political order
everyone's just talking about rights you
hear the left
talking about the positive rights or the
human rights to health care or whatever
and you hear the right talking about the
negative rights or or the natural rights
which is
i think a more serious conversation
what about that word that you just used
lauren what about duty what about the
fact that i'm not just
born into this world entitled to a bunch
of rights
but i'm also born with duty duty to my
family
duty to my community duty to my god and
i'm not
i'm not free in this radical
self-ownership to just do whatever i
want that's not even what our founding
fathers thought liberty
was they thought liberty was the right
to do what you ought to do not just the
freedom
to to indulge in any sorts of appetites
and abuses that you want
yeah and i think that's really the core
of what we're hitting on here is the
both conservative movement and the
progressive movements are now
based on human selfishness and we're
never going to get anywhere on both
sides just arguing over what
what do i deserve what do i deserve um
there's a complete and utter moral
sickness at the core of both movements
in my opinion and until we get back and
i know a lot of people won't like to
hear this and it's not an easy thing to
say because there are a lot of wonderful
atheist conservatives out there but
until we get back to a core of
christianity that believes in the idea
we are
a broken world we are broken individuals
we are not
ubermensch or perfectly feeling
individuals and all my feelings are
valid
no no we are broken individuals that
need redemption
that need to work towards love that need
to work to support each other and let go
of selfishness and until we do that
the only thing that is going to happen
in politics left and right
is going to be human sickness corrupting
the money given to it corrupting the
platforms we have
corrupting the fame and ego and
power the how the power is used if it is
entirely based around
human desires and selfish desires and
nothing higher because we don't believe
in a god anymore we don't believe any
anything higher any more than just
capitalism or socialism
it will all be corrupted and that's this
downward
downward spiral we're in right now yeah
just spiraling into oblivion with
twitter arguments and
i i truly believe when i look at
everyone walking around with masks and
everyone just
screaming at each other in twitter i'm
like did i die and go to hell
am i in purgatory right now oh i forget
i forget if it was moliere or shaw i i'm
getting my quotes mixed up but who cares
it's one of the some old dead guy
who said that hell is the place where
you have nothing to do but amuse
yourself and that's kind of what you're
describing
and this this cult of selfishness has
has really taken hold
not just on the left it was always there
on the left but it took hold on the
right especially in the 1970s and 80s
coincidentally
i just managed finally to make it
through
possibly the worst book ever written
though it gained a lot of
currency on the right atlas shrugged by
ein rand i mean it's unbearable
it's funny that conservatives came to
embrace it to some degree because
when it first came out in national
national review which was the
conservative publication at the time
ran a scathing article bill buckley said
he had to flog himself to read it
he called it a thousand pages of
ideological fabulism
whitaker chambers the ex-communist one
of the great writers of the 20th century
he he wrote a really tough review but
he made it didn't just knock the
horrific prose and the stupid ideas
he he made the observation that has
really weakened the right i think
because they've embraced iran
and and those sorts of selfish ideas
selfishness is virtue
he said randian man like
marxian man is the center
of a godless universe it puts man at the
center of where
nothing means anything beyond our own
pleasure and so
to give ein rand credit what she and the
the defenders of the virtue of
selfishness on their right what they say
is no no this won't descend into
hedonism
this will be the sort of nuchaean
ubermensch we're going to
just pursue our own excellence and what
we want in this in this higher way
but as i look at reality that doesn't
seem to be what what has happened we
just
seem to have descended into decadence
not just
on the left but on the right as well so
how
lauren in our remaining minute or two
how do we get out of it
oh i used to think that book was genius
we all did
we all love dine rand for a spell and
thankfully we woke up
yes i grew up i graduated
i swear by my life and my love of it i
will never live for another man nor let
another man live for mine was the famous
quote from that book
and i just know that all
any inclination that that quote might be
right disappeared when i looked into my
child's eyes
and i think the more the more people we
have the more young people we have
having children
the more they will learn to not be
selfish it is a
complete and utter turnaround in your
life of just
my life is now about another person and
i need to learn
to live for other people and i think
just
right now all we can do is promote the
family promote god and hope that we can
get out of this hell spiral we are in
and i think you're doing good work on
this show with that
well thank you lauren i i actually just
occurred to me as you read that quote
the the famous
john galt oath from from atlas shrugged
i'll never live for another man and no
man will live for me
it is an inversion i mean so much of
that book is an inversion
of christianity the explicit denial of
original sin
the the insistence by one of the main
characters that
money and love of money is not the root
of all evil it's the root of all
good a total total inversion of
christianity and so
it i'm reminded that cardinal manning
was right all
human conflict is ultimately theological
and i have to tell you even though i
missed you during your hiatus
i i was really pleased to see you do it
because i thought man
i knew this chickie was smart but she's
got her priorities in order and i'm glad
that you're back now with all of these
priorities in order and i would
encourage people to go
follow you if they're not doing that
already where can people find you lauren
yeah you can find me on the hell site
twitter at lauren underscore
southern just look up my name lauren
southern on youtube and i'm around there
instagram all those terrible sites that
are wastes of your time but
try to provide a brief break from uh
from the chaos on my page a brief break
where you know you go you worship your
lord you raise your kids you do your job
and then there's that
you can when you do want to dip your
tone to politics you can go follow
lauren there
i really appreciate it thank you for
staying up all night uh kiss your kid on
the head for us
and uh look forward to chatting with you
again soon thanks for having me
will do